[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer sogar
Donald Trump hat gesagt wie ihr eben
gehört habt Boris Johnson wurde von
Beobachtern oft der Trump der britischen
Politik genannt und das hatte beileibe
nicht nur etwas mit dem sonderbaren
Haarschnitt dieser beiden Männer zu tun
oder dass ich stets auch in den
boulevardmedienschlagzeilen machten über
das Privatleben bei der konnte man in
der Klatsch und tratschpresse
ausführlich lesen beide waren dreimal
verheiratet und beide mit jeweils fünf
Kindern als die US-Präsident bzw
Premierminister Großbritanniens wurden
der Unterschied ist das Johnson beim
Nachwuchs noch produktiver war als ein
amerikanisches Pendant trotz oder gerade
wegen seiner vielen partyexzesse hat er
zwei weitere Kinder gezeugt aber warum
denn auch nicht sollte nicht jeder
Politiker auch seinen Beitrag gegen die
Überalterung der Gesellschaft leisten
und ist es nicht wahrscheinlicher dass
einem kinderreichen Politiker im
Gegensatz zu einem kinderlosen allein
schon instinktiv die Zukunft des eigenes
Landes mehr am Herz liegen sollte
[Musik]
aber genug des gossips und der
Küchenpsychologie wir wenden uns der
Politik zu und auch da hatte die
Amtszeit Johnsons einiges zu bieten
schon sein Sturz ist bemerkenswert vor
fast drei Jahren noch feierte er einen
fantastischen Wahlerfolg und wurde
britischer Premierminister er erreichte
die größte konservative Mehrheit im
Parlament seit Margaret Thatcher und das
will was heißen noch im September 2021
hatte er die Vision noch weitere 10
Jahre an der Macht zu bleiben damit wäre
der dienstälteste britische Premier der
Neuzeit
Boris Johnson sieht sich ein weiteres
Jahrzehnt an der Macht also nur ein paar
Monate bevor er zurücktreten musste sah
er schon wie er Margaret Thatchers 11
Jahre überholte es kam aber anders es
wurden nur drei und vielleicht auch wie
bei Trump fragen sich bis heute viele
Menschen wie schaffte es dieser Typ
überhaupt ins Amt des britischen
Regierungschefs wie sieht die Bilanz
seinen Ehre aus und was hat wirklich zu
seinem Sturz geführt und kommt Johnson
vielleicht eines Tages wieder zurück nun
diesen Fragen gehen wir in diesem nach
und siehe da schon der Anfang seines
Berufslebens verlief alles andere als
sagen wir mal geradlinig man könnte es
gerade zu folgendermaßen formulieren
Wahrheit ist relativ
denn Johnsons gesamte Karriere weißt du
einige Momente auf wo er es nicht so
ganz genau nahm mit der Wahrheit dass er
auch über seine Partys in Downing Street
das Parlament belogen überraschte
Insider der britischen Politik also
nicht sonderlich aber fangen wir am
Anfang an nach dem Schulbesuch am
renommierten eaten College studiert er
klassische Philologie an der Universität
oxfad danach begann Johnson seine
berufliche Laufbahn als Journalist für
die Times zunächst ein Praktikum was
aber nicht lange Werte er hatte nämlich
gelogen und zwar hat er ein Zitat
erfunden noch dazu von seinem Patenonkel
Colin Lucas dem späteren Präsidenten der
Universität Oxford für diese Fälschung
wurde er gefeuert aber seine
journalistische Karriere war damit nicht
vorbei er kam beim Daily Telegraph unter
dort schrieb der Kolumnen und wurde
unter der konservativen leser- und
Wählerschaft bekannt Anfang der 90er
Jahre entsandte die Zeitung ihn sogar
als Korrespondenten nach Brüssel
und was bekam das Blatt dafür eure
skeptische kolumen in die versagt kasmus
und Polemik nur so strosten johnson ließ
keine Chance aus die EU-Institutionen
lächerlich zu machen da behauptet
Johnson schon mal dass die EU britische
Würstchen und krabbencocktails verbieten
wollen oder dass die EU die Kondomgrößen
deshalb standardisieren wollen weil die
Italiener kleinere Penis hätten nun es
gab tatsächlich schon einmal eine Streit
über die damalige Norm DIN 600 für
Kondome in der EU die Franzosen wollten
die Normgröße etwas größer die Italiener
eben etwas kleiner und angesichts von
Normen über den Krümmungsgrad von Gurken
und Debatten über das Kondom
Fassungsvermögen muss man fairerweise
sagen dass die EU selbst Johnson mit
genügend Themen versorgt hat die sich
polemisch oder satirisch aufarbeiten
lassen nach seinen Jahren in Brüssel
zurück in Großbritannien arbeitete er
weiter als Kolumnist und kandidierte
erfolglos für das Unterhaus landesweite
Bekanntheit erlangte aber ab 1998 durch
seine ständigen Auftritte in der BBC
Satire Sendung have I got news for dafür
erhielt der 2003 sogar eine Auszeichnung
den British Academy television Award von
Best Entertainment Performance schon
seit 1999 war aber auch ganz seriös
Chefredakteur für das Magazin das
back-tator das ist eine
Wochenzeitschrift für Politik und Kultur
konservativ und Euro kritisch in der
Ausrichtung allerdings musste Johnson
den ehemaligen Verleger versprechen dass
er nicht fürs Parlament kandidieren
werde das Versprechen hielt aber nur
zwei Jahre 2001 schaffte er den Sprung
ins Parlament für die konservativen
Tories und wurde er wegen seines
gebrochenen Versprechens beim spectator
gekündigt nein das verzieht man eben
schließlich konnte er während seiner
Tätigkeit die Auflage um 10% steigern er
blieb noch bis 2008 bei den Magazin
trotz seiner Tätigkeit im Parlament und
2008 steht für einen Meilenstein in
Johnson Karriere
[Musik]
er wurde Bürgermeister von London und
beliebt war auch noch die Londoner
mochten ihn den Entertainer mit
Auszeichnung auch international gewann
der Popularität spätestens seit den
Olympischen Spielen 2012 die damals in
London stattfanden damals wählten in die
Londoner auch ein zweites Mal zum
Bürgermeister was will man also mehr nun
Boris Johnson wollte mehr er kandidierte
bei den Parlamentswahlen 2015 und
schaffte den Einzug ins House of
comments für die Konservativen versteht
sich und dort angekommen kämpfte er für
eine weitere Sache den brexit johnson
war damit einer der prominentesten
Persönlichkeiten die sich für den
britischen Austritt aus der EU stark
machten im Gegensatz zu David Cameron
damals Parteiführer theories und auch
Premierminister und wir alle wissen wie
das Ganze ausgegangen ist die Briten
sagten bei bei EU Cameron trat zurück
und hinterließ einen Scherbenhaufen die
anti-eu-stimmung verfing bei einem Volk
das gerade eine Rezession durchmachte
schaut euch mal diese Grafik an man gab
der EU die Schuld an der schlechten
ökonomischen mein Name ist des Landes
aber frei von den Lasten und der
Bürokratie Brüssels würde es wieder
aufwärts gehen zumindest dachten das
damals viele doch bevor man richtig frei
war musste man sich entflechten und das
war gar nicht mal so einfach vor allem
nicht für die neue Premierministerin
Theresa May die eigentlich keine brexit
Befürworter war und der Protagonist
unseres Videos nun Johnson kandidierte
damals nicht einmal als Regierungschef
obwohl man meinen könnte das Amt wäre
genau jetzt das richtige für so ein
brexit Tier nämlich meine einen brexit
hier nein stattdessen wurde er
Außenminister und wir wissen nicht ob
ein premier Johnson zu diesem Zeitpunkt
das brexit-chaos besser bewältigt hätte
als seine Regierungschefin Theresa mai
wir wissen aber dass may völlig glücklos
ergibt und scheiterte vielleicht war es
eine der undankbarsten Jobs der Welt für
die Premierministerin mit der EU in
Brüssel langwierig den Auftritt
verhandeln in London das
Verhandlungsergebnis zur Abstimmung
bringen und scheitern immer wieder
scheitern es gab damals schon große
Zweifel ob der brexit überhaupt machbar
sei am 7 juli 2019 kündigte sie ihren
Rück und für johnson war der Weg frei
ganz nach oben zu kommen
[Musik]
24 Juli 2019 wurde Boris Johnson
Premierminister des Vereinigten
Königreichs und auch mit ihm als Premier
hörten die Querelen um den brexit nicht
auf Durchsetzungsvermögen hatte seine
Partei im Parlament ebenfalls nicht denn
damals leitete Johnson nur eine
Minderheitsregierung also rief Johnson
Neuwahlen aus um die patzsituation
zwischen Label und seinen Tories zu
berechnen
im Wahlkampf versprach er zwei konkrete
Dinge zu erreichen in brexit endlich
durchzuziehen nach dem Motto get the job
dann und das zweite war in extrem weit
links stehenden leberschaft Jeremy
Corvin als Regierungschef zu verhindern
dieser galt vielen als linksradikal
antiliberal und obendrein als
antisemitisch ein toxischer Cocktail der
Name die Briten lieber das kleinere Übel
in Kauf
Johnson hatte also Erfolg am 12 dezember
2019 gewann er die Wahlen und eine
komfortable Mehrheit für die Tories
sogar klassische labour-wahlkreise
gingen damals an die Konservativen den
Menschen dort war der linkspopulismus
eines Kolben einfach schon zu suspekt
Kolben war also besiegt und jetzt ging
es um den brexit hier hat Johnson
geliefert und Wort gehalten das Abkommen
zur Loslösung aus der EU stand und
erlangte Zustimmung der brexit kommt am
31 Januar 2020 endlich vollzogen werden
[Musik]
doch diese kontinentale Scheidung des
Jahrzehnts erweist sich für viele bis
heute als Enttäuschung und viele
Regelungen sorgen für kopfverbrechen es
fängt bei der Frage Nordirlands an das
weiter dem europäischen Binnenmarkt für
waren angehört diese Regelung sollte den
Grenzverkehr mit Irland erleichtern aber
damit gehört Nordirland automatisch
nicht zum britischen Binnenmarkt da
stecken noch jede Menge Konflikte drin
es wird noch immer hart um den Status
einer ganzen Region gerungen in der die
Menschen eigentlich gedacht hatten das
Leid der Vergangenheit überwunden zu
haben es handelt sich um den großen
Stachel im Fleisch derjenigen die sich
die große brexit-freiheit erträumt
hatten eine Art brexit-karte machte sich
schon deshalb bereit weil die
Befürworter den Austritt in rosaroten
Farben gemalt hatten und zwar so dass
der bloße Austritt aus der Europäischen
Union so etwas wie eine Turbo für die
Wirtschaft bedeuten würde und das
plötzlich alle reicher und wohlhabender
sein würde im jene unsäglichen blühenden
Landschaften die auch schon den
Deutschen in Ost- und West versprochen
worden waren aber nur wenig Militär
Realität zu tun hatten
kurzfristig mussten durch den brexit
endlose Anpassungen von Regeln und
Gesetzen gemacht werden die die
Wirtschaft verlangsamten was auch zu
Unsicherheit führte und immer noch führt
so hat er brexit laut dem Center for
European Reformen im Vereinigten
Königreich bisher für einen Rückgang der
Investitionen und des Handels um zehn
Prozent geführt verglichen mit einem
weltweiten Wachstum von 6%. natürlich
kann der brexit eine große Chance sein
aber das erfordert Zeit Geduld und vor
allem eine Politik die die britische
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit verbessert und hier
hat Johnson eben nicht geliefert er hat
stattdessen haufenweise Geld ausgegeben
und sogar noch die Steuern für
Unternehmen erhöht das hat auch dazu
beigetragen das sind Einfluss innerhalb
der konservativen Bewegung schwankt
irgendwann war das fast eben
übergelaufen und da kamen eben ein paar
Partys kanälechen gut gelegen um Johnson
loszuwerden aber es wäre nicht fertig
Sturz des Blonden krauskopfs auf das
Thema brexit zu reduzieren die ihrer
Johnson hinterlässt uns noch viele
weitere spannende Geschichten also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
außen top innen Flop
wie ihr wisst ist in der Außenpolitik
schnelles und agiles Handeln gefragt und
während die Europäische Union eher
langsam und schwerfällig agiert ist
London durch den brexit viel agiler
geworden um international schnell zu
handeln das hat dazu geführt dass Boris
Johnson jetzt im Ausland beliebter ist
als in seinem eigenen Land schaut euch
zum Beispiel an wer sich am meisten
darüber gefreut hat dass Johnson im Juni
2022 ein Misstrauensvotum überstanden
hat
ja wahrscheinlich hohen naschen
bretagnekim Duran in der Tat unterstützt
Großbritannien die Ukraine dort ist man
Boris Johnson sogar so dankbar dass man
in der Region Odessa eine Straße nach
ihm benannt hat man kann wurde Fug und
Recht behaupten London ist als
entscheidender Player mit einigen Tamtam
auf die Weltbühne zurückgekehrt ein
weiterer diplomatischer Sieg war zum
Beispiel des autosabkommen mit
Australien und den Vereinigten Staaten
worüber wir schon mal ein Video gemacht
haben dass ich euch natürlich verlinken
werde schnelles Handeln schien auch
Vorteile in der corona-pandemie zu
bringen
auch hier übernahm Johnson eine
Führungsrolle von Anfang an setzte sich
die britische Regierung stark für
Impfstoffe ein und erreichte in der
Anfangsphase des 11-prozesses ähnliche
Durchimpfungsraten wie Israel solche
Erfolge tragen brexit Befürworter
natürlich gerne mit stolz geschwellter
Brust vor wie etwa dieses Diagramm
doch leider erwies sich der von den
Briten favorisierte Impfstoff von Astra
Seneca als suboptimal er war mit vielen
Nebenwirkungen behaftet und wurde
schließlich zum unfallterible und
Ladenhüter unter den corona-impfstoffen
heute würde sich in niemand mehr
verabreichen lassen und für Johnson
liegt auch vieles andere ziemlich
suboptimal vor allem im eigenen Land
[Musik]
die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
außerhalb der großen Städte wie London
zu fördern als er während die englischen
mit längst Wales Nordirland und
Schottland öffentliche Investitionen
sollten diese Entwicklung anstoßen so
etwas versprechen die wechselnden
britischen Regierung aber schon seit
Jahrzehnten wenig wurde jedoch wirklich
umgesetzt Ungleichheit zwischen
ländlichen Gebieten und London bleibt
extrem alles konzentriert sich nach wie
vor in der Metropole und alles deutet
darauf wenn das dies noch lange so
bleiben wird dabei hatte das leveling ab
durchaus einen Reiz für Johnson und
Schienen leicht durchführbar zu sein
denn seine Mehrheit im Parlament
bedeutet dass die Tories Wahlkreise auch
in den wirtschaftlich rückständigeren
Regionen bekam aber anders als die
klassischen Liberalen Tories aus dem
Englischen Südosten stellten victories
aus den jetzt eroberten Wahlkreisen
mittelenglands und des Nordens eine
eigene Strömung in der Partei da diese
waren zwar auch konservativ aber zudem
noch sehr interventionistisch in ihren
Ansichten von Politik das heißt sie
forderten eine starke Erhöhung der
öffentlichen Ausgaben für Regionen und
Johnson ging darauf ein um also im
ländlichen England etwas zu bewegen
musste die Regierung viel Geld für
öffentliche Investitionen mobilisieren
das Problem ist dabei natürlich dass die
Ressourcen nicht unendlich sind man kann
jedes Pfund eben nur einmal ausgeben was
die eine zusätzlich bekommen muss man
jemand anderen wegnehmen diese
Investitionen zu Wirtschaftsförderung
und die Kosten der Pandemie haben die
Staatskasse natürlich belastet mit
unangenehmen Folgen
Großbritannien ist eines der ersten
westlichen Länder das die Steuern zur
Deckung der Kosten von COBIT 19 erhöht
und trotz der anfänglich hohen
Durchimpfungsraten gegen covert das
britische Gesundheitssystem ist nach wie
vor eine riesige Baustelle mit schier
unendlichen Wartelisten für Millionen
von Patienten um hier Abhilfe zu
schaffen braucht der Staat Einnahmen
aber die kommen nun leider nicht mehr
aus der Wirtschaft denn das
Wirtschaftswachstum ist weit von den
Erwartungen entfernt und noch weiter von
den Versprechungen und der
brexit-kampagne also versuchte Boris
Johnson die staatsgasse zu füllen indem
er zum allseits bekannten Allheilmittel
steuererhöhen können
erhöhte die Steuern auf Gehälter der
Arbeitnehmer um 2,5% Punkte dies wurde
zu gleichen Teilen auf die Unternehmen
und ihre Beschäftigten umgelegt außerdem
sollte der Körperschaftsteuersatz im
April 2023 von 19% auf 25% erhöht werden
und gerade hier zeigt sich dass der
Tausch des Premierminister seine Früchte
trägt denn seine Nachfolgerin tritt und
ordentlich auf die Bremse vor kurzem hat
die neue Regierung unterlist Trust
immense Steuersenkung angeordnet im
Umfang von rund 45 Milliarden Pfund über
deren Umfang debattiert momentan die
ganze Insel und die Diskussionen sind
heftig besonders in Zeiten wie diesen
liegt Inflation in Großbritannien
erreicht mit 9,4% ein neues 40 Jahre
hoch da sich die Krise bei den
Lebenshaltungskosten verschärft ja sogar
zehn Prozent Inflation wurden
mittlerweile erreicht so manches
gebrochene Versprechen Enttäuschungen
Inflation und Steuererhöhungen haben
Boris Johnsons politisches Kapital
aufgezählt und seine Anhänger in der
konservativen Partei geschwächt für die
Tutorials in ihrer Gesamtheit hat aber
jetzt Liz Trust alle Hebel in der Hand
ihre Partei und England wieder nach
vorne zu bringen die Ergebnisse von
Johnsons Politik sind nicht herausragend
den legendären Status eines Winston
Churchill oder einer Margaret Thatcher
wird obwohl nie erreichen außer ihm
gelingt ein Comeback dazu später mehr
denn jetzt werden natürlich viele von
euch einwenden heutzutage treten
Politiker doch gar nicht mehr zurück nur
weil ihre politische Leistung höchstens
durchschnittlich war da wird doch mehr
dahinter stecken oder und ja ihr habt
recht Johnsons Rücktritt hat viel mehr
mit seinem schier unglaublichen
persönlichen Verhalten zu tun also
bleibt dran denn hier wird es wirklich
interessant
[Musik]
Täuschung als überlebensmethode
am Ende war es partygate mit dem
Johnsons Absturz begann Johnson hat
versucht das britische Volk das
Parlament und alle anderen zu täuschen
passiert war folgendes im Mai 2020 traf
sich ein Haufen hoher Regierungsbeamter
in den Downing Street Gardens zu ihren
traditionellen freitagsdrinks und das zu
einer Zeit als es dem Rest der dritten
verboten war sich zu treffen stattdessen
musste das gemeine Volk zu Hause hocken
und durfte nur zum Arbeiten raus social
distancing war angesagt ihr könnt euch
also vorstellen welche Empörung
Nachrichten die diese hervorrufen
Boris Johnsons halt Strafe an Polizei
wegen Partys in Regierungsgebäuden
während des lockdowns daraufhin sagte
Johnson dass ihm niemand gesagt habe die
Teilnahme an diesen Veranstaltungen
verstoße gegen die von seiner eigenen
Regierung gesetzten Regeln und darum
wurde es auch bei den Tories viele zogen
angesichts eines so offensichtlichen
spendes ihre Unterstützung für den
Premierminister zurück doch so schnell
gibt sich ein Boris Johnson nicht
geschlagen er startete die Operationen
redmate
einen verzweifelten Versuch die
Unterstützung seiner eigenen Leute
zurückzugewinnen lasst mich kurz
erklären was ist damit auf sich hatte
diese Operation red need umfasste einige
ziemlich verrückte Maßnahmen zum
Beispiel die Übergabe der Kontrolle über
den Ärmelkanal an die Royal Navy um
illegale Migration zu verändern doch die
Nähe die verfügte gar nicht über genug
Schiffe und diesen Job durchzuführen und
es ist auch nicht wirklich ihre Aufgabe
oder die Vereinbarung Einwanderer ohne
Papiere in afrikanische Länder wie
Ruanda oder Nigeria abzuschieben
erfahren dass du sogar den damaligen
Prinzen Chance dazu seine Neutralität
aufzugeben und diese Politik als
entsetzlich zu bezeichnen und so verlor
Johnson allmählich das Vertrauen der
Tories bis diese im Anfang Juni 2022
einen Misstrauensvotum vorliegt Johnson
konnte das Misstrauensvotum zwar
überstehen aber seine Regierung war
stark angeschlagen und das Ende kam mit
dem Pinscher Skandal Chris Pinscher war
ein hochrangiges Mitglied der
Parlamentsfraktion der konservativen
Partei Ertrag juni 2022 zurück nachdem
er beschuldigt worden war zwei Männer
sexuell angegriffen zu haben angeblich
war er dabei betrunken jedoch kam immer
mehr weitere ähnliche Vorfälle ans Licht
und für Johnson wurde es eng als bekannt
wurde dass er Pinscher zum Rip befördert
ließ obwohl er bereits von ähnlichen
Vorwürfen aus pinschers Zeit im
Außenministerium gewusst hatte zur
Erklärung ein VIP ist in der englischen
Politik eine Art Fraktionsvorsitzende
ein parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer
einer Partei er hat für die
Fraktionsdisziplin zu sorgen und ist
damit eine Art Einpeitscher die treffen
doch das englische immer wieder ist aus
Protest aufgrund des pinschers das kam
ist uns sofortigen Rücktritt der
schatzkanzlers regissonak und auch das
Gesundheitsminister von den Parlament
sehr wortgewandte johnsons-weg ins
Abseits beschrieben
in Resets I have concreting
change and
that'sız ENA precision to have a
possibility to make that change der
Rücktritt dieser beiden Minister brachte
alles ins Rollen
in nur 36 Stunden traten 50 hochrangige
Regierungsbeamte von ihren Ämtern zurück
und das war das Ende von Boris Johnson
als Chef der torris und als
Regierungschef er trat am 7 juli 2022
auch zurück die era-boys Johnson ist
vorbei zumindest vorläufig und ich sage
vorläufig weil es bereits Gerüchte gibt
dass Johnson in die erste Reihe
zurückkehren will ein Comeback wie sein
großes Vorbild Winston Churchill plant
schaut euch mal diese Schlagzeile an
Boris Johnson flirtet schon mit seinem
come back er selbst schürt diese
comeback-gerüchte als wirklich
ausgezeichneter Entertainer ist das wohl
das Klappern das zum Handwerk gehört für
einen guten Unterhalter ist doch eines
klar man muss sich immer wieder neu
erfinden dann klappt auch mit dem
Comeback schaut euch doch das Video von
seiner Verabschiedung im Parlament an da
tritt eine ab den man nicht einfach so
abschreiben sollte astalavista Baby
unintelligible Video schief
Americans Stick up for you cranians
stick of a freedom
Andi
es dürfte also klar sein welchen Plan
ein steh auf Menschen wie Johnson hat
laut eigener Aussage fühlt er sich
voller Energie und ohne jegliches Gefühl
der Verbitterung gegenüber seiner Partei
Johnson ist natürlich sehr gewiegt darin
Leute in Ungewissen zu lassen seinem
Aufstieg in die Downing Street ging eine
jahrzehn fieberhafter Spekulation über
seine Motive voraus wobei jeder seine
Schritte durch das pressbar seiner Macht
Ambitionen betrachtet wurde er wurde ein
Meister darin dass Rampenlicht für sich
zu beanspruchen in all diesen Jahren
Schienen Johnson mit seinem gewitzten
Ausweichmanövern die Spekulationen eher
anzuheizen als sie zu beenden wenn er
nach seinem politischen Ambitionen
gefragt wurde behauptete er was er eher
als Olive wiedergeboren oder von einem
Frisbee geköpft wurde als
Premierminister als Vereinigten
Königreichs zu werden beides war wie
Journalisten damals treffen feststellten
kein offenes Dementi
[Musik]
in den kommenden Monaten und Jahren
könnte sich ein ähnliches Bild ergeben
Johnson wird wahrscheinlich genug Profil
zeigen und genug über seine Nachfolger
lästern um ein mögliches Comeback in der
Schwebe zu halten nun werden führende
Politiker zwar nicht müde
gebetsmühlenartig zu wiederholen dass
eine Rückkehr des geschosssten höchst
höchst unwahrscheinlich sein aber könnte
dies nicht auch das sehr laute Pfeifen
im Waldes sein der ehemalige
Premierminister ist bei den Mitgliedern
der Story Partei nach wie vor sehr
beliebt und hat in den Umfragen während
des gesamten sommerwahlkampfs besser
abgeschnitten als Trucks und sunack List
Trust Zustimmungswerte sind auch in der
Bevölkerung schlechter als es die ihres
Vorgängers Boris Johnson jemals waren
sie sind sogar noch tiefer gesunken als
sein schlechtestes Umfrageergebnis
während des partygate Skandals in einer
Umfrage nur einen Monat nach dem
Amtsantritt von Trust lag sie bei
schlappen -
47%. das ist sogar noch niedriger als
der Tiefstand von Johnson bei -44 zum
Vergleich Theresa May lag in den Tagen
vor ihrem Rücktritt bei 46 Prozent und
Johnson selbst liegt momentan wieder
haltet euch fest bei nur -22 der Appetit
auf Neuwahlen scheint groß zu sein ein
60% der Briten wollen noch in diesem
Jahr darüber abstimmen ob die
Konservativen Unterführung von Trust an
der Macht bleiben sollen laut Umfragen
verfügt die laserpartei momentan über
einen bequemen 30 Punkte Vorsprung vor
den konservativen was nur eine kleine
Veränderung gegenüber dem
rekordvorsprung von 33% vor Trust
antritt darstellt denn ihre
Steuersenkungen bzw der Revision der
Steuererhöhungen ihres Vorgängers kommen
gar nicht so gut bei der Wählerschaft an
die erhebliche Finanzlücken im
Staatshaushalt fürchtet und nicht nur
die Wählerschaft die Bank of England sah
sich gezwungen einen notfallerklärung
abzugeben nachdem die Haushaltspläne der
neuen Regierungschefin die Märkte in
Aufruf ersetzt haben das Foto stürzte ab
und die Kreditkosten für Großbritannien
stiegen enorm an der Grund das größte
steuersenkungspaket Großbritannien seit
50 Jahren wird ohne Zweifel die
Kreditaufnahme des Staates in die Höhe
schnellen lassen ja wenigstens eine
Person mag List Trust
steuersenkungsprogramm Donald Trump
Trump sagte auch trustwirke sehr nett
und sehr gut während er ihren Vorgänger
Johnson nun als Liberalen Bash der die
Seiten gewechselt habe weil er sich für
Walker Windkraftanlagen auf See
eingesetzt hat tja so sehr können sich
die Verhältnisse ändern erinnert ihr
euch noch an Trumps Zitat vom Anfang
dieses Videos
er war stolz darauf dass Johnson der
dritten Trump genannt wird vieles
scheint von dieser Sympathie nicht mehr
übrig geblieben zu sein und während du
beide auf ihr Comeback zu arbeiten
kämpfte eine noch immer gegen Windmühlen
der andere hingegen wird den Alltag
geliebtheit jeden Rückenwind zu nutzen
wissen der ihn wieder an die Macht trägt
aber was meint ihr wie fandet ihr Boris
Johnsons Politik welchen Rat würdet ihr
denn neuen Premierministerin Liz Trust
geben und interessieren euch Rückblicke
auf Staatschefs oder führende Politiker
die ihr Amt verlassen so wie dieses
Video wie immer sind wir auf eure
Antworten und eine angeregte Diskussion
zu diesem Thema sehr gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt
habe was ja gibst du dein like Tassen
und Freunde und vergessen nicht das Abo
mit Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos
mehr zu verpassen natürlich freuen uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen PayPal liegt dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]